Um,
on his first jump off of the cliff in Italy,
the first time you put a wing suit on and it's a,
that one stung a bit.
So it's on pause potentially forever.
As far as base jumping goes,
I'll still skydive.
But it's a,
it's a question mark on the base jumping south.
You such risky shit.
This guy that I was like,
yeah,
skydiving.
That's no big dust sky dive.
I'll jump out of a fucking plane that I will do with my eyes closed every day.
That's the high risk ratio on that one is we're,
we're all set.
What is the risk ratio on skydiving?
Like what percentage of those things go wrong?
It's incredibly low.
Um,
so that you have a main parachute and a reserve parachute.
I don't think there has been a true double failure.
Meaning your main parachute malfunctions,
you cut it away properly and deploy your reserve parachute and have that also
fail in 20 some years.
People die skydiving all the time.
Well not all the time cause I guess it,
you know,
the population of people that do it is not huge.
But I would say the vast majority of people who die skydiving,
they,
they kill themselves,
they make a poor decision.
Um,
and most people who die skydiving die under perfectly functioning equipment.
Really.
So the,
the canopy size,
the main canopy that you're flying the wing over your head,
the smaller it is,
the faster it goes,
the faster it descends.
But also quite frankly,
the more fun it is.
But with fun there's consequence.
So they're our canopies that you can initiate a turn and if you initiate the
turn too low,
you cannot pull the canopy out of the turn.
You will impact the ground at a high rate of speed regardless of what you do.
And if you get under that canopy with not enough experience,
obviously your odds of making a bad decision,
you're going to go through the roof.
So most injuries and fatalities,
at least from the stuff I've seen,
is from people making poor decisions under good equipment or choosing to execute
an emergency procedure,
which would be cutting away your main parachute in deploying reserve,
either out of sequence or doing it too low,
or the reserve parachute doesn't have time to open.
To me,
that's not a failure of the parachute system.
That's the failure of the individual who is driving that parachute system.
So if you have a main parachute and you jump out and you hit the main parachute
and there's a malfunction,
how do you cut off to put,
to get the other one?
So there's two Pilus,
one on each side,
the right hand side.
You literally need to do this in the correct order,
even though people have killed himself by going backwards.
So you pull to full arm extension you,
it's literally just a pillow with velcro that has two cables and the cables are
what's actually holding the parachute on your shoulders.
If you pull that out,
a three ring release system,
which is basically just a load reduction system unwinds itself in,
your parachute's gone and you're going back into free fall and you just pull the
other pillow.
It sounds worse than it is.
And before I had my first cut away,
it was terrifying.
And then after you have four or five,
you're like,
okay,
I got this,
had four or five main parachutes fail.
I think I'm at about seven.
Well,
I've been jumping for 20 years.
I want to hear that man.
I started jumping in 99.
Ah,
statistically I'm actually,
I think under,
uh,
I think it's like one in every 888 jumps,
you'll have the malfunction or a gear failure.
It's honestly like,
it's your first one is an emotional experience,
I would imagine you're saying.
What was the first one?
Uh,
deploying your parachute and just sitting there looking at it as it's because
they want to open and you can,
I can tell now within an instant of trying to deploy my parachute,
whether or not it's going to open or not,
just by looking at the shape by sometimes listening to it and just seeing how it
opens sometimes.
I mean,
so packing a parachute people think is really difficult.
If you can fold a tee shirt,
you can pack a parachute.
Sometimes though you,
you know,
you just get off of the jump and you only have 10 minutes to make the next jump.
So you skip a few steps or you rush through a few steps.
Is that what happened with you?
Potentially?
I may have skipped all of the non essential steps and a few of the essential
steps to get the pair of shoes.
Really.
I was just rushing and I didn't have a lot of experience.
So as stuff in the thing in there and when I tried to deploy the parachute,
it just,
it was asymmetrical.
So sometimes it'll,
it'll open and it'll start spinning and then you're flying with your back to
the,
it gets,
that would be considered an exciting moment,
I would say.
So what happened with you?
What exactly went wrong?
It just came out asymmetrically.
The parachute wasn't opening and we have spinning.
No I wasn't.
I actually was able to recognize just by,
it should come out.
It looks like a rectangle more than anything.
But if you look like a rectangle with its twisted,
there's no way to fix that.
No Way.
So just get rid of it.
And that's what I did.
I looked up and I said okay that's not going to work.
Reach,
pull,
reach,
pull and your reserve open so fast.
Like by the time I felt like by the time I had pulled the reserve handle,
cause I had a handle that point by the time I had moved my arm to three quarters
of extension and it fired off.
Wow.
Yeah Dude.
But the difference,
and you were asking what the difference,
like why is risk skydiving lower is because you have time,
thousands of feet.
Whereas base jumping,
you might have hundreds or if you're really pushing the envelope,
you might have sub 10 feet because you're flying close to the ground to sauce.
You can go did your friend Alex who died,
did he died base jumping or he died wingsuit base jumping.
It's something that I was,
I mean he was my main base jumping partner.
What is the difference between wingsuit base jumping and regular base jump?
Eight regular base jumping.
You just have a quick deploy parachute,
right?
So you have one parachute system when you base jump instead of two because there
is not time for a reserve to open.
So that has just taken out of the system,
right?
So you pack your primary or only parachute very similar to a reserve.
It's designed to open rapidly.
It's designed to take a lot of load.
Uh,
but so base jumping is just jumping off of aesthetic.
Object based stands for building antenna span or earth.
So four types of object.
The addition of the wing suit is really the only difference which allows you to,
like myself personally,
I'm not a huge fan of jumping off buildings and cliffs without a wing seat
because I don't like being from me to that flag when a parachute opens because
if it doesn't open exactly in the direction you want it to,
you better be Johnny on the spot or you're going to have a fucking problem.
So it's to me if you have enough altitude,
you put a wing suit on and two or three seconds,
the suit is mocking forward.
So then your hundreds if not thousands of feet away from the object,
then your parish,
she can open up however you want it to.
Have they made any improvements in the technology or this stuff since you first
started jumping?
Huge improvements.
I mean the first wing suits were literally just fabric that had like the little
thumb loops you'll find on like cold weather,
long sleeve shirts sometimes seriously like Patrick [inaudible],
he kept it on.
That's how they kept it on.
I didn't show up any of those goddamn things,
but I mean,
I think Patrick Day garden is how you say his name.
He was one of the first and they would just sit there and just,
they would just jam their appendages and lock them out and use their entire
musculature to sail this fabric as far out as they could get.
Fuck.
And then the suits now were unbelievable.
So each wing,
like the wing between your legs and the wing betweens,
each of your arms.
So there's three of them.
They're totally independent.
They have a ram air opening,
so the air rushes into that and makes the wings semi-rigid.
So it reduces the stress on your body and they,
their flight characteristics are insane.
You can go,
you can get the suit flying faster,
you can fly it flat or you can float it.
Everything about it is improved except for the decision making process of the
monkey who is actually jumping in.
That's the original one,
Jamie.
Oh,
that guy's dead for sure.
It says madness.
Mickey Morgan,
where he's 100% of that wing suit.
Is that ridiculous?
Well,
who was the first fucking psycho that thought that this was something that they
should try?
It could potentially been,
oh my God,
this guy is like,
he looks like he's living in the 18 hundreds when did they invent these fucking
things?
I Dunno.
I know one of these guys died going off the Eiffel Tower in an exhibition.
This is 1900 right here,
Tina hundred why in the fuck?
Look at that guy strong.
You know what,
man,
if you were living in 1900 you'd probably be like,
listen,
let's just get this over with.
Fuck living in 1900 everyone has syphilis.
Fucking whiskeys illegal.
I'm just jumping off.
Look at that.
That is crazy to see that.
I mean,
that's,
honestly,
I'm not going to lie.
It would probably jumped out of an airplane.
Teen 95 Oh,
he's the inventor.
Earl Stein.
He died in the first attempt.
Oh Jesus Christ.
He died in the first attempt honor to a modern hero.
All right,
settle down.
But here's the thing,
Joe,
there's like 60 some people who are associated with the modern day wingsuit and
testing and evaluating to get it to this point.
They're all dead.
All of them are dead.
Every one of them.
She,
but that suit like,
I mean,
that suit and the difference between that and where we are now,
it's night and day,
but everyone involved in the creation of these wingsuits died in a wingsuit.
Yup.
Fuck man.
That is not good.
Like it wouldn't be a whole lot of black belts in Jiu Jitsu.
Everyone who got to a certain point died.
You know what I'm saying?
It's hard to justify or rationalize the behavior for sure.
I'll be the first person to,
what is it?
Like what,
what is it about jump?
But it's dog.
That's dean potter,
which helped him with his dog.
Oh,
the poor dog.
So the dog,
the dog's fault.
The dog I believe is that looks like Switzerland.
Crazy asshole fucking owner.
So Dean was an insane,
right.
He's a world class rock climber.
He's also dead from jumping wingsuit.
He died and Yosemite's.
Um,
it's like I said,
the technology advances,
uh,
I am not,
I was not there the day the dean died.
I've talked to people who've looked at it,
uh,
as to the conditions that led up to it.
And,
uh,
one thing people generally don't want to do is place the responsibility on the
individual making the choice.
But what from everything that I have seen,
he made a choice to jump at a time when he should not have been jumping due to
visual conditions.
So even though the suits are amazing,
really the only thing that doesn't seem to be evolving as the person that's,
that's jumping at it most of the time,
just like skydiving,
it's just a human being making it very poor choice to include.
Alex.
What is it about people,
and I mean particularly people like yourself that love these thrills.
Like what are you getting?
What are you getting out of the,
other than this mad adrenaline rush?
I mean,
what is it like,
what motivates you to keep doing that?
Uh,
so I look back at it objectively.
I think when I initially started pushing hard down that path,
I was trying to replicate a headspace or a feeling or a sensation that I had in
my old job.
So if you want to talk about clarity of thought,
and I think we might've talked about this the very first time that we sat down,
stripping away all ancillary bullshit that has absolutely no meaning,
but for me at least spend,
I spend 99% of my time worrying about things that have no impact whatsoever,
right?
So He's sitting on a helicopter,
did you pick the battle space that you're in and you,
you get a five minute warning and you really stop worrying about whether or not
you have enough money in your checking account to cover your mortgage.
And then you get a three minute warning and then you kind of stop worrying about
whether or not you just had an argument with your wife or you just sent off some
snarky email.
Then you get a one minute warning and a 32nd warning and the closer and closer
and closer you get,
everything has gone.
And it is still to this day,
the,
the sensation and state that I have been in that is by far I had no question
about uh,
my purpose and I had the utmost clarity that I've ever experienced in my life.
And you get,
you get used to operating in that headspace of just being in the moment,
the first one to three seconds in front of you,
nothing else matters.
I'm going to solve this problem and move on to the next one.
This problem,
move on to the next one.
Well then I lost that ability to do that and it sucked because I liked operating
in that headspace because it,
it helped me deal with all the other bullshit in my life because it reset for
me.
My,
what matters and what doesn't matter.
Ratio I was able to get rid of like I would describe it,
it just the white noise in my head or go another way.
I would describe it as like,
Jamie's got a bunch of levers that he can push up.
I think in this,
I'm included in this,
I think most people are pegged out at a 10 almost all the time.
They're fucking white knuckling through life.
But if you can get into that state where you have that clarity of purpose,
clarity of focus.
I felt like it pulled everything back to a three and so that state helped me in
things that had nothing to do with that activity and it lasted for a long time.
So when your base jumping and you're standing on a cliff and you're scared out
of your mind and you can't talk as your mouth is so dry and you have the p rang
on your suit,
which is why you always get dark suits so people can't see your peering ring and
every alarm bell in your body is telling you don't jump.
And it had the same experience.
I wasn't worried about checking account,
wasn't worried about what was going on in life.
I was just living in that moment and it helped me be a better dad.
It helped me be a better husband.
It helped me be better at any business decision that I need to make because it
allowed me to Paul,
all of those stereo levers back down so it's less for me and I can only speak
for me it's less about a thrill seeking cause I get that all the time.
Like you're an adrenaline junkie.
I'm like Ah,
I enjoy,
I'm going to adrenaline enthusiast.
I certainly enjoy that but I actually like what I get from the activity more
than the activity itself.
What do you think is going on where people are pegged at 10 all the time with
nonsense and that's something that's life threatening can bring it back to a
three and offer clarity.
I mean the has to be something that you've discussed or thought about in depth.
I just think it helps you
control alt,
delete your hard drive a little bit.
It helps by not having,
like when I'm standing on a cliff,
right before I get ready to jump,
there is absolutely nothing that I am thinking about other than where I want to
be in the next three seconds.
And by being able to focus on something so singular,
and maybe I don't,
I don't meditate,
but I've heard people talking about it by a male to clear your mind.
It helps them deal with everything else.
I think there might be some connection there.
Um,
but I just,
I just think that
the removal of the noise that bombards everybody all day long,
even for a little bit,
helps you.
It's,
uh,
you know,
yet you have a iPod or not iPod,
iPhone and headset.
Headphones for sure.
[inaudible] you ever noticed,
like when you're listening to it,
you listened at the same volume level,
but then it just doesn't seem to be as loud.
So what do you do?
You Click it up a notch,
right?
And then you get used to that volume level and then you click it up a notch and
then you get used to that volume load receptor downgrade phenomenon.
Your body gets used to it,
so it adapts to it.
But if you pull that stimulus out and leave it at that high volume,
but listened to it like two weeks later,
it's going to blow your ears out.
Hmm.
It'll seem loud.
It's not gonna blow your ears out,
but it's going to seem much louder than it would if you slowly just
incrementally started adding that volume.
So it's,
there's something in there that is allowing me,
and I'm not recommending that anybody pursue therapy via the directions that I
do,
but there's something in there that's allowing me to,
instead of ad an ad,
an ad,
that activity allows me to detach.
And then when I come back to it,
I realize,
you know,
it just,
it just feels different for me.
I don't know if that's a good description of the mechanism,
but that's the best that I can probably describe it.